well it's just embarrassing for a family
to go through what they're going through
and and horrifying that it even occurred
it's a sad thing
Martha Stewart who went to prison
herself in 2004 sounding off on the
college admissions scandal actresses
Felicity Huffman and Lauri Lachlan both
potentially face prison time in the
ongoing case it's show biz can't make it
up
eg spoke with the lifestyle icon at the
Hollywood Reporter's at 9th annual most
powerful people in a media event in New
York City I guess when you're in front
of an audience of several million people
on The Today Show or I'm Stephen Colbert
or Jimmy Fallon or one of those no I
never get nervous oh it's nothing to get
nervous about it's sort of like fun
you just recently launched a new line
inspired by all of your basically yeah
well I had four beautiful homes that
I've worked on his laboratories and and
each one of them is quite different from
the others and we are adapting our
designs to reflect all those different
lifestyles and it's working nicely
[Music]
[Applause]